hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream q
and a section with cats drinking stuff
all right it is time to answer your
super chat questions
i feel prepared to you pretty prepared
yeah all right good even though that was
a
long conversation we just had uh but
we're gonna do it that's the thing you
don't wanna you don't wanna give
totalitarianism short shrift you don't
wanna be underprepared for
totalitarianism no you also don't wanna
offend it
i think i might okay yeah fair enough
all right uh
last so i'm gonna start with a few
questions from episode 49
that we've got a question that comes in
from the discord server once a week
and then embark on the questions from
last hour before coming to the questions
from this hour
uh last time we spent a fair bit of time
talking about helium
as one does and someone commented i read
a good book about helium could not put
it down
yep i get it i like it yeah i like it i
figured you wouldn't that's pretty good
yeah
yep
okay um another comment rather than
question from episode 49
the woke left and conspiracy theory
right both suffer from the same
affliction
apophenia finding fake patterns of evil
in events where none exist
fake patterns of evil
in events where none exists so it's uh
this is an argument
for um a superstition
i agree there is something sort of uh in
search of
boogeymen of various kinds um
yeah yeah and i think you know that's
what when people talk about someone
being a conspiracy theorist
that is um the the savvy version of that
i think is trying to get at like god
you know excuse me you're going to find
pattern we're not exist you're
you're being a verificationist you're
looking for a boogeyman etc
yep yep all right um wow we have a third
cat
calling from the other room wondering
where his milk is
um excuse me could male homosexuality
emerge as an adaptive response in
populations with patrilineal transfer of
material resources
less male offspring with offspring
less male offspring with offspring means
less competition over inheritance which
means
maximum status for the eldest so fewer
male offspring with offspring means less
competition over inheritance which means
maximum status for eldest question mark
yep i am still hoping the world goes
back to normal and we can rent a hall
and we can have this discussion
flat out but i will say um as a first
pass yes i think you're in the right
neighborhood the older brother right
hand rule
which says that the more older brothers
you have the more likely you are to be
gay
but only if you're right-handed actually
fits the
pattern you're proposing here and we
will go more deeply into it
later with a proper haul rented
god damn it
[Music]
next question do you two think do you
two think
that things classified as mental illness
are adaptive mechanisms which might have
been used for survival and reproduction
in the ancestral past but manifest
deleteriously
in the present environment depends which
ones
yeah exactly so you know mental illness
is a bad category
some some of them are going to be
mismatch
so-called mismatch diseases uh which are
uh
our current environment is so out of
whack with
our ancestral environment um that we are
not adapted appropriately to what is
going on now
um but some i mean there are also mental
illnesses that are entirely novel
themselves
uh and then there are others that are
called illness which
you know shouldn't shouldn't be
considered illness at all or just
representative of the range of you know
call it neurodiversity
uh that actually has existed
historically
and should continue to exist now without
being
medicalized or drugged into submission
yep so i would i would agree with this
and i would say even the ones that are
real disorders though are in general
malfunctions
of adaptive patterns so there's a
question about
is the pattern itself of a pathology
and is the manifestation
also you know the manifestation will be
pathological in many cases but
if it's built of adaptive stuff and you
know there's good stuff on this like
randy nessie's work on depression
which suggests it's an adaptation out of
place
all worth considering good
why are dolphins and whales seemingly
actually altruistic
such as swimming around humans in the
presence of sharks is there an
evolutionary element
there's always an evolutionary element i
am simply going to make the phylogenetic
comment which otherwise you would make
and then i'm going to let you
pick up the altruism question um which
is that dolphins are whales
so saying dolphins and whales is is fine
but it's like saying humans and monkeys
or humans and mammals
we it is true that we are a distinct
piece of that group
but just like dolphins um evolved from
whales and are therefore still part of
their original group
um so so it is true for us and primates
and
mammals and vertebrates and all of these
things but if you say whales
including dolphins then people like us
will know that you're in on the
phylogenetic reality of the thing and it
doesn't
really matter that much for most
questions no it does it does because
if you if you just simply sign up for
the phylogenetic interpretation of this
stuff
and you say you know whales including
dolphins that's one level of
insight that you get just from simply
having understood that that is a
nested set but then you can say stuff
like
dolphins including orcas right and the
point is each of these things tells you
something really
cool about the evolution of these
creatures so anyway what was the
question though about altruism why do
are they do they seem to be altruistic
like when they swim around humans in the
presence of sharks are they
what's going on yeah well first of all
you're talking about some
among the toothed whales which is i
think what you're talking about you're
talking about
highly intelligent creatures who have
certainly noticed
that we humans seem to control a good
deal
of um stuff surrounding their well-being
so it is possible
so let's just just as long as we're on
phylogenetically you said tooth so
basically you've got veiling whales
whales is a good group
that evolves from um
hippos hippos i'm trying to think of
what's the what's the big
group called i can't think of what the
including group in latin is called
anyway something cetacean oh uh
said ardiodactyl said ardiodactyls yes
um
so um having gone back into the ocean
you've now got whales and they're
grouped into baleen and toothed whales
and the tooth whales are basically all
those things that we know of as dolphins
including orcas and then there's one one
big-bodied whale that's toothed
oh uh sperm whale sperm whale yeah
everything else is bailing well and
they're
they don't tend to engage in this sort
of thing so you're probably pretty much
talking about tooth whales and maybe not
even
all toothed whales yeah first of all
there's a whole group of tooth whales
that are um
bizarre and little known because they're
pelagic
oh it's bigger than what i just said
then it includes more than the
i believe beaked whales is a
subclade of toothed whales sperm whales
is a subclade of uh of toothed whales
dolphins um what else anything else in
there
dolphins and porpoises i believe
together
inside of toothed whales in any case
so there's a question about whether it's
altruism whether it is
reciprocal altruism in other words does
doing well by humans result in some kind
of
benefit sometimes is it a misplaced
adaptation so for example when
people have been seen to be drowning and
dolphins have come to their rescue it is
possible that that is a dolphin
responding to a sense of
a fellow traveler in need
or it could be that it has a reflex
to um to take a d to
preserve a drowning member of its pod by
putting them up to the surface and that
it's misdirected
um my guess is that dolphins are
too smart for it to be an accident
they're not
they're not confused about that not
being a dolphin who's drowning if it's a
person
yeah i mean you know lots of reflexive
things that even a smart creature can
get involved in but this seems awfully
complex
yeah so i don't know yeah probably not
altruism but um
uh collaborativism collaborativism
a kind of reciprocal altruism uh and
yeah i mean dolphins are like us
extremely social and long-lived and they
have generational overlap and yes they
live in extended family groups
and they you know they care for members
of their growth but
group both can and not and
the idea of expanding that sense of
family of group
to to include someone not even up their
species
is something that you know frankly most
humans couldn't manage
it seems but but
maybe many dolphins can and actually i'm
not sure that's even fair what i just
said because
there are a lot of people who may not be
able to see the value in
say preserving wild animals who still
love their
dog yep for instance i would agree with
that i am concerned though you gave a
long list of similarities between us and
dolphins and you did not do
the work of the balancing list of
differences
oh no yes i did not i just go for it do
it um
so i studied uh wales for a time in
college
i was in a marine mammals program and i
did learn that they are aquatic that's
one major difference
they are very i didn't even know squeaky
and they have flippers well the the
squeakiness is probably on kind of all
the salt water
they probably just need more grease ah
nope because
freshwater dolphins are also squeaky
they are yes you've heard this
or you've just read in a book um i
prefer not to comment okay
all right we've gotten silly because
we've
been in front of a camera for too many
consecutive minutes that's right
that's right okay um this question from
the discord server where once a week
people pose questions and they vote on
which question they'd like us to answer
and this week the question they would
like us to answer
always big questions that we can't even
begin to fully answer but they've always
been good so far as well
is what are your thoughts on birth
control methods particularly any
possible long-term effects of hormonal
types
if you had girls how would you advise
them on the matter
god that's so many questions and there's
it's
so good and um you know just to start
with the final one
first you know part of
part of why feminism
when it has made sense has looked the
way it has in the past and why
modern feminism often doesn't look like
it makes sense
is actually based on the correct
recognition
that to be female and to be male is
different and
that effectively contraception
effective contraception with you know
one large exception
um you know the condom basically falls
falls to women and
this is you know is it fair no is it
true
yes and is there any way around it it
doesn't seem to be not yet
you know it would it would be great if
there was work on
um possible modes of contraception for
men
uh that didn't involve condoms and i'm
sure there's some but there's not nearly
as much
but it's also physiologically harder to
get it to work which may be why there's
not
as much i think i believe that that is
true
yes um for reasons that are interesting
which maybe we'll come back to us
yeah yeah maybe we will um so yeah
hormonal birth control
is um
is not perfect you know when when the
pill was first introduced it was at much
higher doses
than it has been for a long time um
i was certainly on you know very very
low-dose pill for many
many many many years and at some point
decided that basically i hadn't been
an adult without having exogenous
hormones
that were working as contraception and
that didn't strike me as a particularly
good idea much you know it is it is
certainly less worrisome to me than
allowing
children and um and teenagers to take
cross-sex hormones
which is um currently all the rage among
some
medical professionals but it is also
there is no reason to think that it is
totally harmless
even at very low doses that said
there is a way to mitigate the harm the
potential harm
of hormonal birth control for women that
is mostly not done
but could basically um not necessarily
mitigate the harm but provide
a adaptive advantage that was never
imagined when
the pill was first on the market that
could actually
help which is to say that in among
hunter-gatherers
most females girls and women experience
something less and i'm
i'm making up a number here and it's
going to vary across undergraduate
societies
but something less than 15 menses
like you know bleeding events menstrual
cycles
in their entire lifetime in their entire
lifetime
and this is because it's not that they
are pregnant their entire lives
but that the combination of being
pregnant during which you have
amenorrhea you're not you're not
menstruating and then when you are
breastfeeding
at least on demand and more and with
greater than a frequency of i don't
remember what it is every
six or eight hours or something you have
what's called lactation elementaria you
don't um you don't menstruate
um due to the effectively the competing
hormones of producing milk
in which you know the adaptive reason
being if your body is producing milk for
an extent
baby or toddler then it is not yet the
time to get pregnant again because you
are still working to
to feed a child um and the combination
of you missed one yep um so there's
um lactational amenorrhea
there is gestation uh gestational and
there
is starvation although i don't know if
that's what yeah
but you know a few uh female marathon
runners for example are often so lean
that they don't menstruate
so basically the body has all of these
protections against getting pregnant
when having the resources to raise a
child
is not evident and so anyway those
you're saying in principle could be
borrowed as a well specifically
it seems that so rarely in human history
until post-industrial revolution
have women had so many periods
uh that uh there is decent
reason to think and not enough research
yet
uh that having so many periods actually
can cause long-term health effects like
for instance anemia that that much loss
of blood over that
you know that that reliably can cause
things like
iron deficiency and so you know why not
if you are taking a very low dose
hormonal contraception uh take it not 21
out of 28 days
but 28 out of 28 days and
and don't maintain uh demonstration so
you know originally the
the dude who invented it imagined that
menstruation was an absolutely necessary
thing
um you know and there were all sorts of
you know weird ideas around cleanliness
and dirtiness and
and women's reproductive um health not
being
um something that uh was being
considered as carefully as it might have
been as it probably would be now
um but if you know if if the pill
instead allowed for say you know one
menstrual cycle in a year as opposed to
13 of them
that would have only a slightly greater
effect with regard to the exogenous
hormones
but it might actually have a a positive
effect in the other direction of
not having the women who are on them uh
have
whatever negative health effects there
are from having so many menses
and it would almost certainly preserve
fertility
uh for longer this is probably true
so anyway we can argue about the various
costs and benefits of that but
um but anyway that's probably probably
the case
yeah but yeah i mean very very low level
um hormonal birth control
is not perfect there's nothing there's
nothing that is
oh no lesbianism works like a charm
yeah okay
all right just thought i'd mention it it
is very effective
um so i've heard it yes yeah uh
yeah um i mean there's
yeah you know there's there's stuff that
is
um that some people really don't
abide things like the copper iud which
is apparently extremely painful for some
people and the hormonal iud is not
recommended if you
are not um past your desire to have any
anymore or any children
um diaphragms are messy but effective
it's it's there's not a perfect solution
and the hormonal ones are by far
the most sat and forget and easiest
um but there are potential long-term
effects yep
all right so just a word on why it is
harder to generate
male birth control yeah if you think
about it
males because they have two reproductive
strategies one of them does not involve
investment males are basically built
with a strong bias in favor of
fertilizing females irrespective
of the wisdom of that
because basically if a man is not
intending to stick around then
though the offspring he may produce is
very costly the cost doesn't fall to him
and therefore might as well sort of like
seeds falling from a tree might as well
germinate even if they land in
bad soil because the alternative is
no no functional offspring so
anyway the idea is female bodies are
much more reluctant
to produce offspring because the cost is
so damn high that
they only want to produce offspring when
conditions are hospitable
and therefore it is easier to interrupt
that system because that system is
looking out for all sorts of conditions
that say it's not a good time to
reproduce
yeah so anyway that bias is
not inflicted by the patriarchy um the
patriarchy may find it convenient
but um nonetheless i mean that's that's
actually the thing that a lot of
a lot of what gets uh put on the
patriarchy's bill the patriarchy may
have
been using opportunistically but wasn't
actually its invention that's right
mostly we in the patriarchy were just
very very
lucky we did not set this up we would
not have thought of it we would not have
had the dedication to make it work we
just
lucked into it and we're sorry
are you though yeah sometimes a little
bit
a little bit mr white so this was a huge
super chat
uh donation thank you and uh
what it the thing that comes with the
super chat donation
is a is a video and it reads mr
weinstein consider this donation a
request to review
this video i've produced which combines
uh yuri
deegan daigan i'll never get it right
dagon's findings with the findings of a
youtuber named
lao y-86s that i believe proves
conclusively the loudly hypothesis
the video is designed to be
understandable to the layman as well so
the general public will understand
so um i'm excited to look at this
i can't promise i'll spend the whole
couple hours
unless it seems like you've cracked the
case in which case i will
all right good next question
how confident are you that generations
who are overly affected by social media
and in turn are much less
able to concentrate we'll still be able
to produce great doctors scientists
pilots etc
careers that require a special kind of
person
wow i'm not confident in the general
ability but i am confident that
every generation has its misfits and
that misfits
are um capable of
weird stuff by virtue of the odd path
they've traveled and so
there will be uh good doctors scientists
pilots etc what you don't want is a
system that's inhospitable to them
because they are um ill-mannered
uh yeah so with without without all the
social graces
right yeah prone to say awkward stuff
that sort of thing
um so anyway yes uh um
preserve your misfits
and they can carry you through tough
times
yeah and keep the children off social
media as long as as long as you can
and the pets keep the children off the
pets
no the pets off the social media
i feel like if we had the pets on social
media and get the children off things
might be better
even more cat videos both senses of the
term maybe the cats would put up child
videos
that'd be weird yeah
i'm going to try this conducted
in-depth research regarding this
situation
i wonder if there's another question
from this person hold on hold on let me
just say
okay um
oh no this is actually coming right
after the previous question i think
conducted in-depth research regarding
the situation i believe it's a
decades-long trek toward unipolar global
governance
nwo new world order new world order
build back better slogans shared by the
u.n and others
equals destroy nation states and then
build back better
please comment on your view of this
there's only one respectable view of
that
what could possibly go wrong um yeah no
idea whether this is the plan it does
sound like the kind of thing that could
be
idly or not so idly invented
in certain circles where people have
the sense of what might be possible and
do not appreciate the danger of
unintended consequences
falls squarely afoul of the principle
of subsidiarity which i think any wise
non-utopian um
person attempting to build bigger and
more effective systems would have to
subscribe to so
fill it out principle of subsidiarity
the principle of subsidiarity which
weirdly comes out of catholicism and i
have never delved far enough to find out
how
exactly that works but subsidiarity
means
that everything should be governed at
the lowest effective level
right so this idea that what we need is
global governance and top-down stuff
is going to be a disaster because
there's lots of stuff that you don't
want regulated at that level
on the other hand there's some stuff you
will need regulated that you have to
somebody's got to protect the oceans and
the atmosphere
and you know police certain kinds of
incursions and ultimately you'll have to
build things at that level too
so how do you do it well the idea is
figure out which is the lowest level
that you can effectively govern
something
and that's the level that it should be
governed and then only those things that
have to be governed
globally get governed that way so anyway
i hope you're not right this is
somebody's plan
to replace nation states with something
higher up because
it will of course end in disaster
i need advice i'm a crack addict but i
got a cushy no-show job because my dad
is a big shot he's running for senate
should i give my incriminating laptop to
rudy giuliani
but seriously what are you guys dressing
up for as for halloween
that's el quinn he he writes in reliably
interesting yes um i think here's the
thing
i know that it's a bad idea drop into an
accent no
no okay my own okay
um i think it's halloween's cancelled
kids
it has to be it's too too soon between
the end of halloween and the beginning
of election day
and i just think there's there's too
much danger of people spooking each
other
okay well three things obviously coveted
changes um
halloween for for children quite a lot
and presumably for adults um
two i'll speak only for me but i i just
never really got halloween
my mother and actually my mother and
sometimes her
best friend and business partner uh
contributed as well made me the
most amazing elaborate elaborate
costumes
when i was when i was little and they
were
gorgeous and i enjoyed um enjoyed that
one night of
living in some other space but i never
got i never dreamt of it i didn't i
didn't look forward to like i get to
i get to be in this liminal space i get
to be pretending to be someone else i
just
that wasn't that wasn't a fantasy that i
had in my in my life in general
and i do i have since long before the
current madness
wondered what is it about
um some people who as adults um
really crave the dressing up and the
changing the personality
and the excuse to act in ways that you
wouldn't normally
act you know that said i i say that at
the same time that i honor
and am truly intrigued by the liminality
that is experienced by people at
carnevale
and you know the the the breakout
celebration that happens in advance of
lent
so uh i don't i don't really don't get
the american version
of it and i think it too often reveals
a deficit in people's lives but
third thing halloween this year is on
the full moon
which means that um you know if the
weather's nice where you are at the very
least if you know if people were going
to be want if you enjoy seeing people
wandering around and
interesting in in different clothes than
just being outside on the night of
halloween could be
actually it's what's today um i guess
it's i guess it's two weeks from today
um but it's it's an actual full moon
this year which is which is fun
i had not realized that of course it is
not surprising that you would have
realized that
and i am wondering if there's not some
deal to be struck it's probably too late
for this huh
no no no because that's not gonna work
no it doesn't it's not a uh
it's not a good listener yeah no it's an
excellent listener it just doesn't act
on the basis of it um here's the deal
i'm wondering if we can strike perhaps
for next year
right you and i will dress up and we
will spare
no expense we will go all out for next
year's halloween
if everybody else will stop
scaring the [ __ ] out of us on the other
364 days
a year okay all right yeah it just seems
like and then we get out of the scaring
each other game
totally and then we go all in for one
night that seems
better absolutely all right
all right there has been so much noise
about stimulus to fix the lockdowns what
an income tax refund of 2019 taxes up to
say the first hundred thousand dollars
of
income tax to be a simple effective
solution
nothing to corporations or free riders
at first pass that seems like a
potentially
decent approach well i'm wondering if it
isn't um
if it isn't a tad regressive in fact it
may be very regressive
those who need it most are likely to
have paid least
those who would get the most well so up
i was going to say maybe up to you know
maybe that up to 100
000 is too high right like so maybe
uh up to 50 000 of income
and then if you know if you only made if
you made it at the poverty line or less
then you
get double your refund or something like
this well wait a second that was a
hundred thousand dollars
in tax or a hundred thousand dollars in
income income
is it clear from the question yeah it
says 100 000 income
oh so it is clear from the question yeah
in fact spelled out in english
in english well done um yeah all right
well still i think it is
inherently a bit regressive but it's not
to say that you couldn't fix it
um yeah i think it's fixable um
and you know nothing to corporations or
free riders
uh yeah i think there's some i think
there's something there
yeah uh so we had three
three super chat questions asking where
are the podcats
and then podcats and then my last five
bucks to give to the podcast thanks
everyone at darkhurst for your time and
effort to construct and convey thoughts
that are passionate
you're welcome and also you are welcome
for the podcats
yeah i don't know where they are yeah up
to no good would be my guess oh
no doubt chewing on bromeliads again i
imagine
okay greetings from phx is that phoenix
i think that's phoenix i'm not sure um
you both married maintained your last
names and you had children together how
did you hash out whose last name your
kids would take
pro and con analysis to different
approaches question mark
yeah um so there's well yeah
there's at first thought there's there's
kind of three possibilities right like
if we're going to keep our own names
which
um which we didn't we were just always
going to do
um at the point we have kids the kids
could have brett's name they could have
my name or we could hyphenate their
names
hyphenating names isn't sustainable
beyond one generation and
um and you could combine names too i
guess which in our case would have
pre-produced the whinings which would
have been terrible
so um in part me
not taking your name brett uh was
the slightly unusual thing not at all
unusual in our sphere in our circle
uh and there was never i never imagined
you know at any point in my life that i
would end up taking
my husband's name because uh you know i
am i am
who i am um and love you dearly and hope
to be with you
forever but um i am not my identity
isn't
your identity despite what occasional
people who mail us may
think um with regard to you know mr and
mrs brett weinstein really
no you're not going to get any money
from me if you send me that piece of
mail
um but because we happen to have a
patrilineal society which is different
from patriarchal and different from
patreon local petra lineal's this
anthropological term
which just identifies that
that names and
sometimes the other stuff like property
and and such go along with it
are tracked through the father's line as
opposed to the mother's line which we
matrilineal
in general um children so in general
women take their husbands names when
they marry and the children there
thereafter have the father's name as
well and that's a patrilineal society
having a rule in society that is either
patrilineal or matrilineal makes good
sense
and i don't find one um particularly
oppressive
right um i didn't take urine simply
because
i am who i am and i don't need to
subsume my identity to you but
um but having the children fit into the
model that is dominant in society
makes sense it's it adds clarity and
specifically
why would there be a rule of
patrilinearity petrol lineality rather
it is that uh because in mammals and we
are mammals
uh certainty of paternity is never 100
whereas certainty of maternity is
what are you saying uh you know exactly
what i'm saying
[Laughter]
so even though you and i and our
children are all 100
confident that those children are your
children as they are my children
um society does cannot know that with
the same certainty
and so whereas i know for sure that
those are my children and it doesn't
plague me to have them walking around
with your last name
you um being their father and having
them be
them have my last name inherently raises
questions in people's minds that there's
just no reason to raise
yep right so i don't we never we
actually i don't think even ever had the
conversation i think we just sort of
understood
all of that between us as evolutionary
biologists who
are also trying to live in the world
with kindness and
generosity yeah no i i think that
if i can just encapsulate that please
were the kids to have
your last name and not mine it would
suggest
something about where those kids came
from that was in fact
not true so it would mislead um
and so in any case this seemed like the
best of a bad set of choices because
truly none of the choices
are all that great from the point of
view of a world in which women do have
their own identities
and somebody either loses their identity
or you main two
maintain two identities and then you you
know you hyphen hyphen hyphen or you
don't hyphen and you solve it for one
generation so
there's no perfect solution yeah right
like it you know it would be easier if
we all had the same last name as
as was true in both of the natal homes
from which we came
right um but
but you know we were born in a different
era when that wasn't
um understood to be the thing that
needed to happen and
and it's it's a little bit messier yep
um but uh this seems like
the least messy while getting the most
value from being able to
you know fully retain the identity of
the adults going to the relationship
while um still allowing the um
children's
names to reflect um reality with care
yep now of course there's a there's a
trade-off
built in if the children have the
father's name
then it's more or less clear where the
children came from but
the father does not have plausible
deniability if the children turn out bad
i'm just pointing it out yeah putting it
out there you know something i don't
no so far the kids have been great um
but you know you never know
you never know what sort of kids you've
got until
they've grown old i guess
um so this uh thank you for taking the
time to discuss dreer's uh
uh book i'm glad you have brought to
your attention i hope your listeners
appreciate its content so this is the
person who
uh pointed out last last week thank you
ethan thank you for pointing it out to
us yes indeed um
next question could non-rivalrous
coordination be a prerequisite for
societies to survive the technological
development necessary
for interstellar travel would this
selection pressure mean any et species
we encounter is all but guaranteed to be
peaceful
that's a good one that's a really good
question yeah it really is
um um
well i think you can think it's
necessary unfortunately it would be cool
if it were
so here's the thing you got to remember
that
human beings cooperate to compete
we can now globalize that we can say any
collaborative
species collaborates that is there's
collaboration within the species not
that the whole species collaborates
any species in which there is
collaboration
will have that same explanation can you
can you
can you sort of expand the idea of
competition
to abiotic things like you're competing
against the you know darwin's hostile
forces that he never knew
which is how do you get super liberal
travel
um i don't i don't see that in the
question i think no i just um
to your point if we cooperate to compete
as humans in general what we mean when
we say that is that we are cooperating
with others like us to compete with
others like
us uh could you could we expand
could that metaphorically be extended to
we are going to cooperate
to compete against this problem of this
you know this abiotic problem of how do
we how are we going to travel beyond the
speed of light for instance
right well i think the answer to your
question
is that compete
involves two kinds of competition so
there's the obvious kind of competition
which would be called interference
competition
which involves disrupting your
antagonist's ability to do stuff
and then there's exploitation
competition in which you just simply use
a resource
and therefore there is less of it
available to your competitors
and in the case of abiotic forces
basically the point is
you can be perfectly peaceful and expand
to fill some
niche and you're still competing right
and so i think what i see in this
question
is um you
you there's certain things you don't
want to bring on the spacecraft
like your instinct to get into a bar
fight right
and so if bar fight is sort of the
you know the height of poor judgment
with respect to the
worth whileness of um fighting
right you would want to back that
instinct way off
for anybody who's going to be on a ship
with you for a long period of time
and so barring hibernation
should we expect extraterrestrials when
they get off the ship to be very
collaborative and then should we expect
them to come from very collaborative
species
i can sort of see it but i don't think
it's a requirement for the same reason
you point out a we would expect any
creature that had attained that capacity
to have been a ferociously good
competitor that's how you get those
capacities
and so i guess i would expect very
powerful
very competitively competent critters
that are very good at uh keeping a lid
on it
right um so no bar fights i would not
you don't expect when the aliens do in
fact land
on the planet to find evidence of bar
fights in their spaceship
this is your position yes this is this
is my position yeah
i am learning physics
do you know what dude can you it
probably says in
perth washington but i don't know is
there a perth washington this is my
question it seems like perth is in
australia
or at least it was not in washington um
so
i'm just gonna i'm learning physics in
perhaps perth washington
with a class called integrating
indigenous science and stem
like brett mentally i must resist their
consistent illiteracy
acknowledgments of country etc how can i
fight back safely
please give me eat a reference to catch
22 which i read from a couple of
podcasts ago the ways you can fight back
are
innumerable the way safely they'll fight
back safely
are probably an empty set at this point
that's well i know i told you you got to
be safe i mean it's not it's nice no and
that's and that's part of
um you know there's so much more in this
book that we just spent a long time
talking from um let's live not by lies
but um
you don't always need to be taking
aggressive action against the idiocy
that is coming your way but
um there is no end of resistance that is
possible
right and um almost none of it is
totally safe
i would say the safest approach
is uh humor
and charm and that is unlikely to work
on your woke detractors
who are humorless and insensitive to
charm
as a trout
but uh but you could practice by trying
to charm trout
trout yes and if you can charm trout you
might be able to charm
the woke teacher in front of the room
actually am i right
no that no i think i might be okay that
uh fly fishermen effectively
charm trout they totally do so charm
your
woke teacher with a hook
no wait it's fly fisherman not right
yeah no that's so yeah yeah
um but yeah i think the answer is
what the thing that you can do that will
protect you best
is to cause yourself to be
well liked amongst those who aren't
committed to this
particular revolution will that make you
safe no no but make it look like fun to
be where you are
yeah make it look like a good choice
right don't like
especially given that the the webster's
seem so intent on being dour and
humorless
and musicless and um just filled of
filled with outrage and hatred um try
filling your life with other things
and and making it visible right like
laughing
and smiling and i mean even just that
the the amount of distance that a smile
at someone you don't know can go
is is huge and even you know even now
and covered times with
i don't know if you're doing this by
zoom but if you're in the same room and
if you're
masked a smile with your eyes
is actually revealing of of
actual tenderness that um
that most people respond to
could science ever be compromised to the
degree that would be required to debunk
evolution should it interfere with the
wider global agenda
boy i mean we're seeing this right now
yeah um
you know can it continue to go that way
i think the one
the one saving grace here is that
whatever it is that doesn't allow its
science to be corrupted will immediately
start out competing whatever it is that
allows its science to be corrupted
yeah and therefore um the fools can do
whatever they want
arguing that uh you know sex is
a construct and
yeah it's all tools of the patriarchy
right but
i mean i mean already the evolutionary
biologists
are distrusted and maligned
um by many in the social sciences i was
someone saw
that i'm an evolutionary biologist in my
twitter bio and told me i must be a
social darwinist
which is insane like you know a
eugenicist
right like no those aren't the same
thing that's a bastardization
of evolutionary thinking that's not what
evolutionary thinking gets you
but uh this people aren't educated at
this point enough to know so
could it get worse yeah it can get worse
yeah on the other hand
darwinism has made itself vulnerable um
it needs to get better and fast so
let that be a warning to you okay let's
do
three more here and we'll come back to
some of these next time and then go
to this hour's questions what are your
thoughts on totalitarian government
control and the ensuing division it is
causing as it relates to covet 19
especially in the face of inclusive and
uncertain scientific findings
is the question how are totalitarian
regimes doing relativity no i think
and i apologize if i'm misreading the
question but i think that the question
posits without claiming that it's
positing uh that things like lockdown
and mandatory mass requirements is
itself totalitarian
yeah i think this is this is a tough one
because in effect we are now dealing
with technological realities like
airplanes that make epidemics
and the possibility of generating
endemic
uh pathogens that follow us around and
things
these things are now very serious
realities with major human consequences
the fact that we may have to be somewhat
totalitarian to
deal with pathogens
is not to me a sign of something having
gone wrong it's a sign
of our novel uh world
requiring us to suspend certain
sensibilities
with respect to things like uh pathogens
however
i would just say i don't think
totalitarian authoritarian a bit
but i think totalitarianism is a step
beyond and that this is a
a a value judgment that is is not right
here
i i that's kind of what i'm saying is
that
effectively you know is
are the laws that presumably surround
the um uh hand
washing and other uh protections
in an operating theater is that
totalitarian
right i don't think it is totalitarian i
think it's just smart
yeah um are pilots being required to to
check in with uh with air qual
who's in the tower what are they called
air traffic control air traffic control
is that you know is that authoritarian
no that's that's regulation upon which
we all depend if we're going to be
flying or
or um going into the knife yeah so
anyway those protections are necessary
that said the novelty of this situation
with
kovid does open the door
to governments taking advantage of
fears both uh real and unjustified
in order to do other things and so at
some level we've got to get control over
our governments
so that they don't abuse these powers so
that when they actually have to utilize
these powers we can trust that they're
doing it for the right reason
yeah um i guess i would just add quickly
uh our
i i told you i was in conversation with
one of our good friends from grad school
who i won't name here because i didn't
ask her in advance if i could but um
she's been living in sweden for many
years with her partner and
they're probably going to stay there um
and well a
quite apart from this question she is
actually reading hannah arense on
totalitarianism
right now and and seeing some scary
things in it um but she also i asked her
you know what what what has it been like
there and
it looks it it seemed like sweden was
doing something strange and
not appropriately responsive early on
and then
death rate was lower for a while and
then maybe it's getting worse again
what's going on and she said you know
um actually
people here really trust and respect the
government
and our death rate continues to not
um not be as high as almost anyone
outside of sweden was expecting
and the thing that really surprised me
was she said
there are no mask mandates and most
people are not wearing them
and my sense my friend says is that
this is because the government it hasn't
been
deemed necessary yet but the government
has the sense
that if they make it a mandate everyone
will comply
because the government is trusted and so
there's this distinction
of we don't we don't we don't
apply these rules haphazardly or
casually such that when we do apply
rules
when we do make new rules we know that
we will have compliance
because the people know that we don't
take them lightly interesting this yeah
this struck me is very interesting i
haven't really followed up
yet but super interesting um i just want
to note that i feel like
i'm hearing mice in our walls yeah
because there's no cats back there at
this point and i think we have mice
fair enough yeah would you mind telling
me about how cellular memory works
please
is an akashic record possible or
immeasurable
um i don't know what the second part of
that question means at all do you know
what the first part means or is this
immunological
memory i don't know if there's a thing
out there called cellular memory
it's nothing i've exactly i've not heard
it in those
terms all right so i'm going to assume
that what you mean is immunological
memory cells and what happens
is when you get sick
you have let's go before you get sick
you've got when you are in utero
oh that's really well before you get
sick well before you it's
even difficult to get sick at that point
um
you have a diversity of cells in your
immune system that are predisposed to
react to different
configurations of electromagnetic charge
on the surface of things
you have effectively every possible
combination at some
low level of resolution and then those
cells that have these capacities that
react to your own tissues
disappear from the set they kill
themselves off and leave no descendants
so what you have is a system
that is prone to react to anything that
could
enter your body that doesn't match your
own formulas right
now you get sick and
the um pathogen has a unique signature
it's not like you and so it triggers
some subset of these cells a very tiny
subset
that subset then goes through a process
of clonal selection
where it produces
offspring cells that have not exactly
the same formula so it produces a
diversity of offspring cells
that subset that is most reactive then
produces another generation and so
over time it discovers the formula to
nail that pathogen
at the point that you've destroyed the
pathogen you get the triggering of the
production of memory cells which are
basically
a subset of cells that remembers the
precise formula
necessary to counteract that pathogen
and then those things can last now i
don't know what it is that causes
some of these memory cells to last
different periods of time in other words
some kinds of immunities you have for
life
some kinds of immunities you have for a
period of time and then you need
to be revaccinated it could be that that
is because the pathogen is changing at
some rate and so your memory cells just
aren't up to date
i need a firmware update essentially of
course you did
yeah of course i did but in any case
that's basically the idea is
it is a process called clonal selection
in which evolution inside your immune
system
hones in on the formula and then having
found the formula
a subset of cells that are long lived
is retained after that army that was
built up to fight the
the infection is gone excellent
okay one more question from here and
then we'll switch to
this hour's questions you said that
bernie and yang were asking the right
questions
but you weren't sure about their
solutions what do you think is the
solution for wage stagnation
well i think we have to rethink our
entire approach
to uh to training and
work for a world in which uh we're
automating jobs out of existence and
leaving people with
you know a massive service industry that
doesn't justify the kinds of salaries
that would allow them
to raise children um so anyway i think
the point is
you can band-aid stuff
uh i think there are arguments to be
made for things like ubi
i've argued before that something like
participation income might be better
um because it lacks the perverse
incentive and
implied in ubi um but i mean let's just
face it we've got a
obvious crisis on our hands we have huge
numbers of homeless people who didn't
find anything
useful to do now some people were
homeless
10 years ago so maybe there are people
who just couldn't have done anything but
the fact that we have an increase in the
number of homeless
people obviously means that people who
were finding something useful to do
aren't finding it now so
we've got to build a system that
actually protects against that ebb and
flow
and anyway
doesn't mean we shouldn't engage in
processes that address this to some
extent
but uh you know this is why i say i'm a
radical as i actually believe
that the flaws are so deep that they
need a very substantial rewrite in spite
of the risk of unintended consequences
we need to do it carefully
but it needs to be done nice okay
starting at the top with this hour's
questions
while at the playground with my
two-year-old we noticed the swings are
no longer tied together
her response was that means the
coronavirus went away
should i report her for spreading false
information yes
absolutely uh-huh yeah what are your
stats for the very least
oh yeah yeah yeah okay next question
is there some biological truth to
astrological personality traits
can factors like amount of sunlight
exposure in the womb and mother's
seasonal diet influence development of
embryo at different stages
create personality patterns linked to
the birth period this is a terrific
question
and we actually speak a little bit to
this
in one of the chapters of our book if
and this is a huge if you control for
where
you were born and not just when
then yes you absolutely should predict
and in fact there are some extremely
large scale studies that show
that uh birth month when you control for
birthplace
are uh predictive of being susceptible
to for instance certain types of
diseases
absolutely as you would expect but the
vast majority of
astrology is doesn't doesn't in any way
control for where
and could not possibly be predictive of
anything
if uh if you know if being born on june
17th
in uh imagine there is a perth
washington in perth washington versus
perth australia
totally different experiences you would
expect in fact the opposite
um i actually don't know exactly where
perth is in australia but
um doesn't matter still the opposite
well it's it's the opposite
in terms of seasonality but i don't know
how seasonal it is there
right right so um but you would expect
something like the opposite
um in terms of what diseases are more
likely depending on what month you were
born in
yep uh so um i will just say
it's obvious that these things that
astrology can't have any general utility
because to the extent that your annual
cycle of seasonality
um is particular to where you are and
that that might have implications
to the extent that you have astrology
absent
birthplace information right but
astrology effectively never has
birthplace information so the point is
well i mean
no that's not actually true right so
like you know the pop the pop
astrology that everyone is familiar with
has none of that
um but i don't know about originally but
that but there are people who
uh when they you know want to you know
read your signs whatever i don't know
the language of it
um but will not do so without taking
down information
about um where it was that you were born
as well and they and they and they build
their understanding of
what you will be like based on that now
i think then they will tend to build a
whole lot of additional things that they
can't they can't
possibly be known or predicted from
um time and place yeah of birth um
but you know the the the pop the pop
astrology is
clearly without any merit but once you
include the other thing which
apparently non-pop uh astrology often
does
there is the potential for some for some
predictive power
on some on some fronts like disease risk
and even maybe some personality stuff
i'm not buying that astrologers do this
i am
i agree with you of course that um
that a an intersection between the time
of your birth and the place of your
birth means that you sit somewhere
in the seasonality of your weather
of the harvest of all of these things
and that that could have predictability
your mother could be outside with you
right right all sorts of stuff that
could manifest in personality in
particular ways
um i i'll be very surprised if there is
an astrological tradition
that is global in the sense of
soliciting information about where it
was that you were born
and when and it would also need to know
how long you remained there
since we don't remain in the same place
for life in order to know what the
effects were there would have to be some
sort of a theoretical
basis for understanding that a person
born in mid-winter
you know is going to have these
personality traits well it doesn't need
to be theoretical it could be strictly
empirical
well but the problem is in order for an
astrologer to do this
they would have to get this information
and then extrapolate in other words oh
you were
born in you know in los angeles in april
of
1969 but you immediately moved to
new guinea right that would have been an
interesting different
life trajectory for me yes it would have
been a very different but the point
is you would need to make that
correction and therefore you would need
to have some sort of
model in which the point was okay yes
born at time and place has implication
that implication decays based on how
quickly
you moved on from there phrases i mean
it does
raise some interesting questions around
like how long will it matter i would
think it would matter only for maybe the
first year of life
right like you mean that the pattern the
effect the actual effect
of being born a particular time in a
particular place
thus allowing accurate prediction
accurate astrological prediction that
includes the all-important place
information and not just the the date of
birth
but the but the but the place of birth
information as well
um by the time you're you know two i
think it's certainly by the time you're
three or four
um the seasonality isn't going to matter
it's really it's the very early stuff
you know we're born effectively still
still we still should be in the womb but
our
pelvises can't accommodate giving birth
to babies that are any bigger than they
are and so
those first six months of life are
effectively still
um you know like unborn babies and
whether or not it's winter and therefore
you're spending time inside and
therefore more susceptible to getting
say colds and flus
uh as opposed to its summer and you're
more likely to be outside and getting
more exposure to
sunlight and vitamin d uh is going to be
really important i would think for the
first
six months year maybe and i would think
after a year it shouldn't it shouldn't
matter if i had in fact moved to new
guinea
in april of 1970 a year after i was
born from los angeles i don't think that
would have had
any effect on a a savvy astrologer's
ability to predict
my uh personality well
no i would say it goes on longer than
that okay potentially
um and that basically if you think about
the
massive revolution that is constantly
going on in young children like
you know up to the age of five
that a pattern of cyclicity that starts
at a particular place
is going to have uh okay different
impacts based on you know your first
summer and your second summer and all of
these things
yeah um in any case it is also possible
that part of what
astrology is is a misapplication
of local traditions that once were tuned
into something
right yeah so that you know that people
were very convinced that it was real
because it
you know people you know astrologers
whatever they were were tracking
local phenomena that were real and then
the point is oh this works
right for some reason where the stars
are which tells you when in the year you
are
and you already know where you are
because that was implied in the fact
that people weren't moving very far
right
um so anyway all of those things are
possible um that said i think there's
just
no reason to think modern astrology that
is
either global or going to be arbitrarily
local is tracking anything well i have
anecdotes that suggest otherwise but we
won't go into those here
okay yeah so apparently wa stands for
western australia oh
okay of course it does sorry
okay so that was perth
western australia not perth washington
struck us as odd that we'd never heard
of perth washington but we ran with it
yep okay we have to answer at least a
few more of these we've only gotten
uh two so far this hour so um
do you have thoughts on pelosi's
daughter and the twitter sphere accusing
andrew yang of sexism
youtube generally swings the other way
what about these platforms explains the
reliable difference in opinion
i don't have any idea what this is about
do you know
no okay um yeah
so no i don't have thoughts because i
have no idea what it's about
um yeah sorry love you guys
you seem to have way more in common with
jordan peterson than most know maybe
even yourselves
iirc what's irc stand for
zach what's irc
um uh you said you didn't read his first
book
and it takes it'll takes it a long way
to bridging gaps i suggest to read or
listen
p.s when is your book coming
good okay so if i recall correctly you
said you didn't read his first book and
it takes a long way to bridging gaps yes
that's true um
i've read the 12 rules and not uh and
not the first one
i can't remember what it's called maps
of meaning that's right
um no and it's not it's not for lack of
interest it's just that there are so
many
so many things to read yeah so i will
say the
diagram on the cover of maps of meaning
comes very close to a diagram that i
made when i was working on frontiers and
um basically game theory really so i've
always wondered whether that's because
we were
onto related topics yeah although your
stuff on frontiers and game theory uh
would have come later maps of meetings
from the 90s
doesn't matter yeah i didn't know
anything about it yeah and so anyway my
stuff on frontiers
involves a diagram that looks like this
so the question is
is some topic in that book i mean a
maybe the
cover art is just abstract but it's not
abstract
is the topic that he's on that results
in that diagram
in some way related to the frontier
stuff
analogous or is it just happenstance
no and i think i mean i'm i i would say
i'm flattered and i think it's true
that um that we have um
we have in many ways very simpatico
understandings of the world in many
regards
uh to to jordan's yep uh and uh also
when is your book coming
um it seems that uh printers
are um having lag times due to covet as
well
and so it looks at this point like it's
going to be somewhat later than it was
supposed to be
more like the very end of summer next
year very beginning of fall
which is uh disappointing but um
hopefully the world still
exists then and um this is the publisher
is hoping to do a
a big enough print run uh that they have
to be thinking about actually being able
to
get enough copies printed that's all
very strange honestly
um jordan peterson
next question posited that gender
identity confusions may be a downstream
effect of proper
play and development deficit in
childhood a compensatory acting out
does arrested development contribute to
crowd madness
love you too um that's interesting i
hadn't
i hadn't heard that exactly but um
deficits of play in childhood
will have a huge number of effects as
we've talked about
and might some of those be um
gender identity confusion you know just
even not being allowed to
play without adults overseeing you with
members of both the same and opposite
sex and doing a little exploration
yeah yeah absolutely clearly um
so i would go back to my favorite
aphorism good judgment comes from
experience
experience comes from bad judgment right
so play is a landscape
of relative safety low stakes bad
judgment
yes low stakes bad judgment where you
can
try stuff out that sounds pretty right
and find out why it isn't and uh to the
extent that your play
has been moved onto a screen where
some corporation has generated a
compelling visual landscape that has
nothing to do with reality and
only loosely involves other people and
so you've stopped
skinning your knee and your forebrain
and all the other things that you might
skin
um go outside skin your forebrain skin
your forebrain get it get it over with
now while i can still recover
so yes almost no doubt that um
a lot of this stuff where people are
saying patently ridiculous
things that they haven't apparently
discovered are false uh
would have been cured by a proper play
environment where
yeah we perhaps didn't interrupt
them while they were skateboarding
without safety equipment
yes um hi guys do you think the right
the ra
do you think the rise of mercenary
armies like blackwater
could be the result of living in an
increasingly post-national world
uh yeah a globally capitalist
world in which such things nothing can
be bought
anything can be bought i mean there's
also a lot of other stuff like
you know nations trying to evade their
own rules with respect to conducting
military operations
this is true have greater liberty and
offers plausible deniability to the
nations in question so there's lots of
terrible reasons for it but um
yeah and wealth inequality between
nations so post-national-ish
too but wealth inequality between
nations such that you can hire
mercenary armies from poorer nations um
because people are more desperate for
work
yeah yep
were either of you born with a palmyras
longus tendon i wasn't
i think it is an interesting
evolutionary vestige
yes i was not born with one i was able
to source one on ebay
so i actually don't know what it is i
don't either okay um
no idea how would we know uh probably uh
you would have been told because
something that other people with a
polymerase longus tendon can do
uh you cannot or or some such
i don't know uh zack would you look that
up
palmares 44 palmyra's longest tendon
just look at polymer's longest and tell
us where it is
uh i'm thinking it's going to be ankle
um
but i don't know how does one
differentiate between adaptive traits
and maladaptive traits nested in larger
and more adaptive packages
[Music]
well so we've i think talked about the
adaptive test before
if not i have a video on it somewhere in
my youtube channel but um
let's put it this way the adaptive test
works at any scale
it basically says a complex
phenomenon that
is made out of materials or involves
energetic expense or involves
risk in which there is variation in the
amount of expense
and the amount of expense does not go
down over time
is adaptive so if you had
a trait you know let's say that you had
an appendage let's say we're talking
about the wing of a bird and it has a
lump on the leading edge right
well that lump is made out of stuff if
the lump does not go away over time then
it is paying its way
now that is different than what seems to
be
hinted at in your question that you can
have a
trade-off where something that is not
vestigial
is nonetheless preserved though it is
costly
because of some larger benefit that it
produces
and so that's a distinct phenomenon
where the adaptive test is not relevant
because basically
it will come up positive as presumably
adaptive and the reason it will come up
positive is because the net effect
is positive good okay we're going to go
back to palmyra's longest tendon for a
moment zach has pulled up the wikipedia
uh it we're we're no i mean we're good
um this is calling it a
muscle visible as a small tendon
uh basically in in the wrist where if
you touch the pad of your fourth finger
to your
thumb and then flex you should you
should see it
visible and if you don't you don't have
the i don't think i have it
yeah i think i i think you don't and i
think i don't
and uh do i want it didn't you say you
sourced one on ebay
that was a joke oh really yes sometimes
i just don't know you just don't know i
can't tell
uh so yeah given that neither of us had
heard of this before it's hard to say
um we've spoken before about
the use of the term vestigial organs is
often
an excuse meaning we don't know what
this is for yet so we're going to assume
it's useless
but given that there appears to be
according to what what zac pulled up on
wikipedia anyway a lot of variation
particularly within some populations and
it doesn't appear according to wikipedia
to have an effect on grip strength
maybe it is just a variant there's you
know there's lots of variants there are
variants in
um the way the aorta leaves the heart
and um you know some are presumably
better than others but there's also just
a lot of variation
within humans so this may just be
a variant and not that is inherently
disappearing but just
exists and some doesn't exist in others
next question it says second question
but i don't see the first question
uh i'm studying physics
oh is this going to be this is going to
be the person
not in washington but in australia
perhaps
i'm studying physics with dyslexia
dysgraphia dyscalculia
this calcula and aphantasia
i feel like i'm operating a different
frequency to lecturers and classmates
any tips especially
regarding eric i'm not sure what the
regarding eric refers to here but yeah
and i don't remember what aphantasia is
yeah i don't either look that up you
want to
say anything about the different
frequencies brett well
um inability to voluntarily visualize
mental imagery is a fantasia yeah
yeah i've not heard of that um i don't
know you know
here's the thing hopefully your
inabilities are downsides of
abilities yeah um you certainly want to
lean
towards them anything you can do to
separate yourself
from your would-be competitors in some
way that is positive
would be useful and so you know don't
reproduce what they do do something that
your uh particular unique skill set
uh loans itself to and i would say that
that's advice i would give anybody
because everybody
you know some some disabilities have
names but we're all
collections of uh assets and liabilities
that result in unique skill sets and
paying attention to where your skill set
is unique is
clearly a key yep okay so we have five
more questions here i'm going to save
the last one
from faraz for next time and we're going
to quickly go through these other four
questions that
we haven't yet gotten to from this hour
and there's several more from the
previous hour some of which we'll get to
next time as well
in reverse order how do you gain
strength when you didn't have the
stability of an intact family
um uh in in part by building community
uh with you know by by choosing rather
than being lucky enough to be born into
a group of people who 100 have your
backs
it's it's harder to build it but it's
doable and it's important and um
it's harder now without social
structures in place you know without
things like
a church or a synagogue that that a lot
of people go to especially younger
people
but find finding people with whom
you actually share something that is
important
and and bonding with them uh and
then asking them to please
point out to you when you are wrong
right like that's
that it doesn't it doesn't work to just
be with people if they're only going to
agree with you that doesn't help you
build strength
if you're trying to build strength you
need to have people who are willing to
tell you when you
when you [ __ ] up or when um they think
you're wrong and sometimes they'll be
wrong instead but
you need that you need to have that
tension but
coming from a sense of the security of
even when we disagree
we actually respect and love each other
underneath that
i would add uh you need to take your
wounds
and scar over that there is this
fascination with keeping wounds
open and wallowing in their consequences
and the wounds are likely
real but the best thing you can do just
as if it was a physical wound on your
skin
is generate scar tissue and figure out
how to move on which doesn't mean the
wound isn't
you know a historical fact for you but
i would also point out that this is some
place
uh this overlaps our conversation
earlier
my conversation with greg lukyanov
where he talks about the fact that woke
ideology
effectively is the opposite
of cognitive therapy which teaches you
to put these wounds to bed and move on
and
woke ideology causes you to emphasize
them and keep them open
so anyway yeah i believe that this was
actually this is one of his
insights that caused him to reach out to
jonathan height in the first place and
for them to write that atlantic article
and then to write the coddling of the
american mind that his
own experience with when i say cognitive
behavioral therapy
was so at odds with what he was seeing
in students who were so fragile and so
in need of safe spaces
yep yep
any advice on living with a woke brother
who tells me i'm racist
stupid and want people to die because i
don't agree with him
those are the top three insults he uses
can you find a new place to live my god
he's
that's awful i'm sorry i don't know
um you know
if it were me i think i would point out
um
you know at some point you're gonna
realize how wrong that is
and you're just gonna be embarrassed
that you ever believed it
and you might invest now
in some thought process that
won't leave you wanting to flee your own
skin
you know so you're you're this guy
asking the question speaking to his
brother
is that is that the voice you're using
here yeah okay i'm just saying
you know i think a lot of this stuff is
like it's the right thing to say this
minute to get civilization to turn over
some stuff
and the point is you're just gonna be so
horrified that you ever said those
things because they were never
you know right they were never plausible
and um you know i mean i do wonder
at whatever point this turns around
um i think a lot of people are just
going to pretend that they never said
these things
of course they are uh you know they're
going to sanitize all evidence that they
said anything on social media
and if friends or family members are
bold enough to bring it up
they'll say it didn't happen yeah
actually you know what maybe that is a
proper approach what i'm very reluctant
to give people
uh advice that makes any of this sound
like it's not dangerous or that there's
something to be done because i i worry
that there isn't very much to be done
but maybe the point is you know what
would you write that down for me
i want you to remember that you said
that i want you to know
that when you're saying these kinds of
things somebody is paying
attention and at the point these things
turn out to be
yeah uh clearly insane and everybody
understands that
you're not going to be able to walk away
from them yeah right and you can do it
symmetrically you know
no it's not a trap i will also write
down for you what i think
exactly in fact maybe that's the right
one can we put the two
can we both write what we think read
them
put them in an envelope seal it and you
know if you also want a copy fine but
i'm going to keep a
keep a keep a copy i i i like this
actually it's not
pulling rank the point is look you
really believe that let's write down
what we both believe
and freeze it in place and let's revisit
it yeah now that
um freezing what you think
um really being able to go back to what
you thought at the time
is so critical to um
god does so many things to doing good
science to being a good friend
to being in a relationship that makes
sense to you know to so many things and
it's
nearly impossible because our brains
accommodate to protect us from our own
wrongness
and um and they lie on our behalf yep
yeah
that's good i like that yeah another
version of it might be i dare you to
journal it
you you think you've got this all wired
you think you understand how this stuff
works i dare you to journal it and then
just revisit
yes it doesn't have to involve me you
journal it for yourself and then
no i actually i this is absolutely one
of the values of journaling i think you
know journaling in general is um
somewhat gendered right it's more likely
to be something that women do than men
and i and i do and i've done it
more and less um at times but you know
pretty consistently throughout my life
and
i do go back and i do
find it instructive to know for sure you
know
not to say that i was right then but i
do remember correctly
usually um yes i really did think that
then
yep this is like this this was written
contemporaneously
uh with of the other actions that were
happening whatever
so whether or not i was right about it i
am not i have not
sanitized my own memory of how i felt
about it then actually this is the
key to your own thought process
being upgraded is keeping ruthless track
of what you believed and figuring out
whether or not it turned
out to be right it's not always fun but
one does get better at avoiding the
errors if you
spot the pattern yeah okay one last
question for today
do you know why most animals keep their
brains in their heads surely they're
safer places
cheers tim this is such a good question
i know i love this so
we could go so many places with this
there's only one good answer though oh
okay you go first then all right you got
your answer you've locked it down how
vlog you want me to
journal it wasn't that kind of a
challenge
i would just say i believe the reason
is because it minimizes the neurological
distance to your eyes your
uh your nose and your taste buds
so the idea is um so we sort of think in
terms of wires and wires
transmit signals at light speed so
distances like down your arm are not
meaningful it's so fast neurons aren't
like this even though the impulses are
electrical the way
they're actually chemical right it's the
influx of electrons
into or ions into the the axon
that causes the impulse to propagate
down
these neurons and that means it's
actually quite slow
and so the body has to correct for those
things to the extent
you know a giraffe has a much worse
problem getting accurate
immediate timely information from its
limbs
than does a squirrel because it's just a
physically longer distance and the
transmission rate isn't any higher so
anyway the point would be keeping your
eyes near your brain so that the
information that comes in your eyes
immediately reaches your brain and you
can therefore react
in a way that's useful is
desirable and so that's true for every
sensory modality
and therefore
also i would say from the point of view
of protecting your brain a big
vulnerable organ um information where
you know your sense organs are
right near it so that you know if
there's some projectile coming at you
you
are likely to see it right so anyway
proximity to your sense organs is the
short answer awesome
um so that is actually not the answer i
was going to give but the answer i was
going to give
is uh is conciliate with that answer
which is a phylogenetic one
which is to say uh brains actually
evolved brains in
crania involved with the wait for
craniates
which is uh which is sort of an
important moment just after chordates
evolved just after our notochords
uh evolved and just before vertebrates
our vertebral
column evolved so right in there we get
these like
brainy um single brains
in crania uh which is again where all
the sense organs are
and that has not changed once in the
history of the craniata
there are other animals uh like insects
uh that don't technically have brains
and like cephalopods like
squid and octopi that actually have
distributed
uh neural centers and don't have single
brains and it's not that they have you
know brains in their
knees or something but they have
distributed um
distributed centers and with the
exception of the cephalopods
it seems to have effects on how
basically how cognitively
complex they can get and so with um
with craniates which is effectively
vertebrates
who evolved the brain in the first place
it probably evolved
there where all the senses are are
centered for exactly the reason that you
describe
and then it had no reason to move any
move off of that particular local
maximum would have been
immediately destructive of any organisms
that tried to move their brain to their
knees or their butts or wherever it
might have been
thoughts yeah people have tried that
sure which actually raises another
question how many different times
phylogenetically
has a creature with a brain evolved to
not
use it uh many many many times but
always in the hominid lineage
interesting yeah
run into these folks yeah all right all
right
well it was a long one today that was
here we go um
yeah it'll definitely be back next
saturday well
we'll be back either a week from now or
before then
and uh until then
until then as well as you can be given
all that is going on
check your six relatively frequently you
never know who's back there
what uh you're six o'clock behind you
um i'm just saying it's 20 20 you don't
know who's back there so no i don't mice
could be all right uh yeah we will see
you next time
and uh join us on our patreons that's a
good idea
all right be well everyone
you